STRATEGY FOR THE FINAL LEG OF
THE 2020 RACE.
JOINING US NOW ELISA COLLINS,
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS HAVING THE
PRESIDENT IN THE HOSPITAL AND
WHAT EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS NEXT
JUST WEEKS FROM ELECTION DAY?
>> WELL, IT’S A MESS.
IN TERMS OF THE ELECTION IT’S
NOT WHAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WANTS TO BE TALKING ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN THE HOSPITAL
AND THE CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW
IS ABOUT HIS HEALTH AND
CONFUSING SIGNALS THAT REPORTERS
ARE GETTING ON JUST, YOU KNOW,
THE STATE OF HIS INFECTION.
SO THAT’S WHAT EVERYONE IS
TALKING ABOUT, NOT THE PRESIDENT
BEING OUT IN FRONT OF A RALLY.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS MADE
HIS CAMPAIGN ABOUT BEING IN
FRONT OF PEOPLE, BEING IN FRONT
OF A LOT OF PEOPLE, INTERACTING
WITH CROWDS FOR A LONG TIME, THE
CRITICISM WAS ON JOE BIDEN FOR
NOT HAVING CAMPAIGN EVENTS AND
NOW AS HILLARY WAS TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER, JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS HAVE PLANS TO BE OUT ON
THE ROAD WHEREAS THE PRESIDENT
IS IN THE HOSPITAL.
THEY DID ANNOUNCE TODAY THAT
MIKE PENCE WILL BE OUT ON THE
ROAD NEXT WEEK, SO THERE IS SOME
MOVEMENT FROM THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
BUT THIS IS NOT WHERE YOU WANT
TO BE ONE MONTH BEFORE ELECTION
DAY.
SANDRA: IT’LL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW MUCH MORE WE WILL SEE
THE VICE PRESIDENT OUT THERE
CAMPAIGNING AS WE GET CLOSER AND
AS THE PRESIDENT DOES REMAIN FOR
AN UNKNOWN PERIOD OF TIME IN THE
HOSPITAL.
YOU HAD THE PAIR OF EVENTS FOR
THE PRESIDENT CANCELED IN KEY
STATES, FLORIDA AND WISCONSIN,
OF COURSE, WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO
SEE THEN AS FAR AS CHANGED
STRATEGY ON THE PART OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN SO CLOSE TO
ELECTION DAY?
>> WELL, WE SAW THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN CANCELING EVENTS SAYING
FUTURE EVENTS WILL BE VIRTUAL.
THEY DID ANNOUNCE THE VICE
PRESIDENT ON THAT ONE EVENT.
IF THERE ARE HEALTHY SURROGATES,
THEY WILL BE OUT ON THE ROADS
CERTAINLY.
IT IS DEFINITELY BETTER TO BE
OUT IN FRONT TALKING TO VOTERS,
BUT THIS IS A CAMPAIGN THAT DOES
HAVE A VERY STRONG DIGITAL
PRESENCE.
THEY DID USE THAT DIGITAL
PRESENCE RIGHT AFTER, YOU KNOW,
THE PANDEMIC STARTED AND
EVERYTHING WAS SHUT DOWN IN THE
BEGINNING BEFORE TURNING TO THE
TRAIL.
SO THEY CAN TAP BACK INTO THAT,
THE PRESIDENT IS STILL WELL AND
RALLIES IN THE PAST, THEY CAN GO
OUT AND HE CAN DO INTERVIEWS, SO
THEY CAN DO ALL OF THOSE THINGS,
BUT THE KEY HERE IS THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS MADE A HUGE PART
OF HIS CAMPAIGN BEING OUT
TALKING TO PEOPLE AND REALLY
DOWNPLAYING THE EFFECTS OF
CORONAVIRUS, SAYING IT WAS
GETTING BETTER, THE ECONOMY WAS
GETTING BETTER AND PEOPLE NEED
TO RETURN TO NORMAL LIVES AND
HE’S UNABLE TO RETURN TO NORMAL
LIFE RIGHT NOW.
SANDRA: WE HOPE THE BEST AND
MEANWHILE THERE’S QUESTIONS OVER
WHAT THIS MEANS FOR THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS, OBVIOUSLY
CRUCIAL TO THE ELECTION OF AMY
CONEY BARRETT, "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" DIAGNOSED IN PARALLEL
SUPREME COURT.
SENATOR RICK SCOTT DOESN’T THINK
SO.
YOU MENTIONED THE VIRTUAL NATURE
THESE DAYS, THERE’S NO REASON
WHY WE CAN’T GO TOWARD WITH
THIS, LISTEN.
>> SINCE MARCH WE HAVE BEEN
HOSTING OUR -- OUR HEARINGS BY
-- BY WEBEX, YOU CAN SHOW UP IN
PERSON OR SOCIAL DISTANCE WHICH
IS WHAT WE DO, WE ARE IN BIG
ROOMS AND NOT CLOSE TO EACH
OTHER OR YOU CAN DO IT BY VIDEO,
THERE’S NO REASON WHY WE CAN’T
TO DO THAT.
THERE’S NO REASON WHY THIS IS
GOING TO UP-END ANYTHING.
SANDRA: SENATOR MITCH MCCONNELL
PLANS TO KEEP OUT OF SESSION DUE
TO HEALTH CONCERNS, WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT, FINAL THOUGHTS?
>> THIS MOMENT, THE MAJORITY
LEADER SAID THAT IN-PERSON
VOTING IS CANCELED BUT THE
HEARINGS STARTED OCTOBER 10TH
WILL GO FORWARD OR OCTOBER 12TH,
I’M SORRY.
AT THIS MOMENT THEY ARE GOING
FORWARD, THERE COULD BE FURTHER
POSITIVES COMING UP.
I MEAN, THIS IS FOR THE
HEARINGS, THIS IS NOT FOR VOTING
IN PERSON, SO WE JUST HAVE SO
MANY UNKNOWNS.
AT THIS MOMENT IT’S ON --